bread-and-butter question you've got to
be able to get full marks on this
question okay and I would expect this
question would be worth four okay four
marks for easy marks okay I don't want
to see any of you lose marks on this
kind of question not just because it's
simple and you guys can do it but also
because for the next one and a half
years the questions you'll be doing will
all build on this kind of skill right so
if you don't have this foundation right
we're in trouble for later all right
typical question by the stationary
points determine the nature then let's
draw the graph now even though it
doesn't say showing all features bolívar
see how it says hits
hence right so even though it's
something worth two marks they're
expecting to include all those things
from earlier parts of the question all
right so let's give this a go shall we
find all stationary points what do I
need to do to find stationary points I
had a different shape okay now I've also
picked out this question because it's a
classic error to making it right what
you've got is a question so the instinct
you've got especially in an exam when
you're under pressure is go to the
question rule right
but you shouldn't why not because you
can divide it up okay and then you just
get two fractions which are really easy
to deal with rather than doing V Cube -
sorry me you - - UV - on V squared it'll
be a disaster so how do I break a pot x
squared on X is just X and the other
parts
whatever else that's a little more
manageable okay
in fact on my right this is um excellent
- one does that help us with difference
yeah okay so derivative just take each
piece one is five x is what three videos
of X to the minus one what we do this
bring the power out the front sir - and
then reduce the power by one
okay so far so good
now what what I do with this derivative
good now by the way please don't just
say we've said this before don't just go
to next line 1 minus 1 and x squared is
equal to 0 ok because it's it's not but
we want it to be for a particular case
so put your logic in ok for stationary
points ok the derivative is 0 ok and
what that means is this expression which
we just worked out
that's sequence ok can anyone tell me
what the values are we can expect good
ok so there are the X values now find
all stationary points and determine
their nature ok so I've got a little
more to go before I'm actually found it
I know where it's X is which is
horizontal but I'm gonna need to know
where its Y is okay how do I do that
good ok so when I say x equals 1 y is
going to be equal to 2 1 plus 1 we will
have to show some for working but you'll
see later on okay so there's one of our
stationary points okay and the other one
x equals minus 1
I understood now at this point you ought
to be getting suspicious because I
there's a lot of symmetry here right
which we should have picked up earlier
because what kind of function is this
look at it carefully okay think back to
further graphs when lockers the top part
x squared plus one picture x squared
plus one what kind of function is it
it's even bottoms X which is odd when
you have even or odd if you divide them
and multiply them what you're gonna get
the result is also odd you see that one
- right - one - two okay so you don't
need to I mean it's not part of the
question to say should this is an odd
function right but the whole reason we
dwelled on odd and even functions is
because they help you do things like
this and it makes it faster okay
all right so one two and minus one minus
two okay so now what I found them what
do I have to do okay so to determine the
nature you'll remember we've got two
options
right what would one of the two ways we
can go about this okay second derivative
or first derivative okay now have a look
at this function and this is its
derivative which way do you you should
go should we use the first derivative
and drop the table or should we do the
second derivative what what's the thing
that makes us think that makes us choose
what you know let's just remember the
the way that you go about this okay
if you're using the first derivative
okay what you have to do is for each and
every stationary point okay you have to
test values on either side okay and then
you want to show what the derivative is
doing it's going up and then going down
or vice versa okay and then you say it's
a maximum or it's a minimum okay that's
what the strip to free right with second
derivative what do you do you don't draw
this table what do you do you just pop
it in right
you just take one value as it were okay
so which is less work this is less work
provided that differentiating is not hot
okay that isn't is a hard to
differentiate this again it's not that's
not right cuz this one disappears okay
this minus X to the minus 2 just do the
thing again it's a polynomial that's
about the easiest thing different ship
apart from Exponential's okay so I think
we should have like to go the second
here right remember we can you can use
either but we'll try to save time here
okay so I've got um I'm forgetting about
the one cuz just disappears I've got
minus X to the minus 2 okay so I bring
the power down watch out for the double
negative okay and then reduce the top I
want okay now good so I've got my one
and my minus 1 okay so x equals 1 what's
the second derivative good okay now hold
on what does this mean second derivative
is positive which means it's facing up
right okay you can't remember what
concave up looks like of what means you
just draw right right and that means
it's a local so I should say relative
it's a relative minimum
it really doesn't matter I'm saying
relative because local sometimes a
relative other times
oh I should you mean yeah I suppose so
though that seems to be I mean it's like
do you do that one question in
millimeters and meters at the same time
I suppose you could but would you anyway
okay there's what now do you have to say
it's concave up
can you go straight from here to here
the short answer is yes you can
does that mean you should do it I don't
think so okay here's why remember this
is our first time assessing your ability
to understand all of this okay so what
I'm looking for as a marker is not just
do they write down the right stuff but
can they demonstrate they know what this
all means okay like this is greater than
zero so what was that indicate okay why
is it a relative minimum is it just like
because a maths teacher said so no it's
because indicates this geometric feature
which is a minimum right you can see in
the cleaner so that's why I write it I
mean I've been doing this for years and
I still write it got to do it for the
other one okay when x equals minus one
the second derivative is okay by the way
did you notice odd function right first
derivative is even next to it second
derivative is back to odd okay every
time you differentiate you flip between
odd and even anyway so this is concave
down
all right now since this is a question
all on its own
okay you should actually conclude this
this question and actually have a
sentence right so you would say
therefore okay
I've got these two stationary points and
I'm gonna say what the nature is right
so let's say one two is a which one was
this one this one is a relative and the
other one it's one of those things which
information is there however with
something like this I think it's
particularly valuable because you can
see that all of this actual information
which is my answer it's sort of
scattered throughout all of my work so
as you don't want to give extra work to
the market trying to find your stuff and
fail to find it and say this is not
worth what should be okay right let's
graph it shall we
you've got another color just crafted
already okay the first thing you do is
take the information you've already got
right and plot it on there okay so one
two up here and it's going to be a
minimum okay so I'm expecting it to come
up and of course I'm actually not gonna
wear it on the other side because once
I've got this side and I know what it
looks like
it's an odd function so I'm just gonna
go away all right apart from our
calculus what other features do we know
about this thing
good now that's the kind of graph it is
what kinds of income features to the
hyperbola has okay good so where's the
first good don't forget to label your
asymptotes so that makes sense of why
the stationary point is a minima it's
gonna draw back up over here okay so far
so good what happens towards here the
right hand side
okay so it's approaching and you can see
that by the way from here right because
you have that one over X pot which is
disappearing okay so you can draw your y
equals x acetone in there again
critically important to actually label
it and make sure you're a prettier okay
now since we worked it out in part a you
should actually full-on label that and
say this is one suit and you could even
say it's a minimum turning point okay
now I've got that I'm just going to
mirror it across the other sides
finished okay of course this graph
because of the features that it has has
no intercepts but if you if it did we'd
have to graph them okay any questions
about that